slappy Pappy Wang Wang ji spicy should
[ __ ] you with my head as I've explored
Korean culture in New York City one
common misconception is that it should
be cheap fast and delivered in a
Styrofoam container but there's a rich
tradition of high-end Indian restaurants
in New York City that challenged that
expectation and deliver michelin-starred
food worthy of a celebratory splurge
today I'm hitting Junoon with someone
who definitely deserves to celebrate
aasif Mandvi is a hilarious comedian
actor and daily show vet who's killing
it with his one-man show sakinah's
restaurant and we're gonna see what
fancy curry is all about Thank You Asif
for joining me on this lovely evening I
think you're actually joining me okay
I'm joining you yeah I was just here and
then you just came and sat down with
this whole crew it is what happened and
now I've never been here and you've been
here so I'm here all the time
you were born in Mumbai and then you
moved to the UK how do you see curry
change within those cultures the UK has
a very long history with India new
colonialism and all that so when the
British were in India they took our
spices and they went back to England and
they created this dish called chicken
tikka masala and then they brought it
back to India and then they convinced
the Indians it was their food and I'm
telling everyone right now is not our
food and then in the u.s. it's a
different take on curry I mean when I
first got to America and that was like
in the 80s
nobody many people have never even tried
in the info I think still today there
are Americans that have never tried it
in food I think it's still considered a
kind of exotic other food you know
so before we have our first meal yeah
we're gonna toss it to the kitchen and
see what we're about to eat
my name is Akshay bhardwaj I'm the
executive chef at Junoon restaurant
which is an upscale modern Indian
fine-dining restaurant we try to go with
the modern twist on traditional dishes
so that when a guest comes that they
don't feel like they're necessarily an
Indian restaurant they're at an upscale
restaurant that serves Indian food for
Jessa Lina and Asif I've prepared three
dishes the ghost chili mark tikka of the
Shahi lamb shank as well as the lobster
muy Lee so for the ghost chili mark
tikka but we prepared it by making a
marination
with hung yogurt ginger garlic paste
fenugreek powder black salt and garam
masala powder and then we finish it off
with our ghost pepper paste it's not
going to completely destroy a guest
palate but it's still spicy enough where
you appreciate the ghost pepper itself
[Music]
all right here we go now I'm a little
nervous about the ghost pepper very
afraid of no ghosts
I'm afraid of a ghost pepper I here we
go ready okay
that's supervising
whoo how do you like it
just cuz I'm Indian holy like that's
right his body right huh what some Yoga
Yoga can we go to yogurt oh that [ __ ]
hot
bring that empty oh my god somebody just
dropped us a mango lassi my ears are
like sweating holy [ __ ] that is good but
that counters the ghost pepper in a very
delicious way I love what you gonna do
spice but you have like this also about
Indian food yeah so I don't do spice
which is like a huge misconception on
Indian people people think we can handle
like chili pepper after chili pepper
it's really different I think look it's
like anybody else some people have a
little higher tolerance for spicy
somebody's a little low dollars I don't
have a huge high tolerance for spice my
father can eat like just Chili Peppers
raw not always is spice correlated with
like the burning
playa knocking my throat background I
got you you and it gets to the flavors
how important is spice in Indian food
that's that's what Indian cooking is
chefs in India will just sort of Intuit
what the spices are what the spices
needs to be and assertively it's almost
like jazz
you know Indian cooking is like jazz
yeah I know I reminds me when my mom was
cooking and trying to teach me and then
I was like no let me know the exact
recipe legs no throwing stuff in and
then I was like how much it's like
however much you feel what you feel it's
all about throwing a little bit of this
Wilbert them and it's all an intuitive
understanding of how these flavors all
move together and weave together yeah
it's like they're creating this tapestry
of flavor boy town you know I love
adding boy to the NJ boil happy Pappy
went when G spicy should [ __ ] you with
my head
next up we have Janine Shahi lamb shank
the lamb shank is made with black cumin
yogurt curry and got'em masala and
paired with potato salad let's do it so
you just rip it you just go in just go
right in smiles at some point Americans
decided that foods like Indian or
Mexican or considered cheap meats but
they're willing to spend twenty thirty
dollars on a bowl of pasta I mean you
know I think that's changing and I think
it has changed now a lot of the Indian
food that people are exposed to it was
much more kind of you know low-end
cutting now you're seeing a lot more
innovation and a lot more interesting
flavors and a lot of these high-end
places like Junoon are doing really
interesting things like we saw with the
Ghost Pepper dripping I think Indian
food has now become a totally legitimate
high-end food with real artistry and the
kind of sense of a chef bringing their
personality to it so we got one more
dish coming yeah are you ready I am for
the lobster Wow last but not least we
have Janine's lobster Moily the dish is
made with lobster coconut milk fenugreek
tumeric and heirloom tomato I've never
had Lobster in an Indian restaurant
before
it's good mm-hmm
very coconutty mm-hmm I feel like
lobster in a high-end restaurant is a
very common piece that shows you it
indicates that we out here ballin more
than any one particular sort of like
dish I think it's more the innovation
the presentation different flavors the
different influences the
cross-pollination I think that's where
the status symbol sort of is around
Indian food not so much in life whether
it's lobster or duck or in an amine I
feel like I've had a prawn curry so for
me this isn't like so it's similar to
that right but I think you are right
like the more creative they can get the
more high-end it seems right because
they're throwing it together in an
unusual way that actually works so you
have a one-man show coming out in
October it's actually a return sakinah's
restaurant yeah and it focuses on the
immigrant coming here and finding a
place in the culinary world
why is food a powerful connection to
cultural identity as a person who wanted
to tell stories about immigrants who
wanted to tell stories about identity
food became a great access point it
became an entry point into that world
and into that culture we said it in a
restaurant and we use food as a metaphor
for integration do you integrate two
aspects of yourself together
that's what food can do you know you you
take a spice from here you take a flavor
from there you put it together you
create something new and that's what you
and I actually are you're Canadian but
you're many things right I'm American
Indian like British and so we're kind of
this masala and that is the metaphor of
Indian food and and that is the metaphor
into the sort of muddled up identity
that you know we are we carry around
with us well thank you very much for
joining me on this journey through spice
and
thank you very much for inviting me and
for paying for dinner you're paying for
dinner York no I think your paper time
you got the check I got a place to be I
don't think I have the chair I'm what
what I think good yeah I believe
somebody needs to call my agent
because that was not part of the deal
[Music]